世界は多様性であふれています
そうミス防止あげたら皆さんはそうだそうだと思われることではないでしょうか
人種やあるいは宗教そういったものを想い
かぷ描かれる方も多いかと思います
でも多様性の時代は対立の時代でもあります
そうそうやっぱりそうと思われるかもしれません
みなさまどんなことを思い方っていらっしゃいますか
側面6月のイギリスのブレーブス2
食でしたよねあるいはアメリカの
大統領選挙
これを思い浮かべる方もいらっしゃると思います
では日本では
日本では同質性が高くて
調和を重んじるので
私にはあまり多様性や対立は関係ないことだと思ってらっしゃる方が多いのではないか
と感じています
今日私がお話ししたいのは小さな多様性の話なんです
私たちの周りには友達関係ですとか家族
あるいは上司と部下あるいはあ
部門や組織政府や民間といったさまざまな小さな多様性が存在しています
そしてこの小さな多様性は例えば
立場の違い年齢の違いそして人生経験そのものの違い
なったりしますがこの小さな多様性がさまざまなトラブル
あるいは対立を生んでいるというふうに感じています
皆さんが誰かと話をしていてイラッとしたりあるいは
理解できないっていう風に思われるときそこには多様性があります
しかし日本ではどうでしょうか多様性に出会ったとき私たちは調和を重んじたり
思いやりを持ったりしてそれを違和感をそのままにしておく
だまいしておくということを多くの人が選んでいるように思うんです
しかしこれは良くないことだというのが今日のご提案です
名前しちゃいけないじゃあどうするのよっていう話ですが
まずなぜダウンしてはいけないかお話ししたいと思います
多様性が存在したときにそこには
フラストレーションのようなものがありますですから
生産性がまず下がるといいいいたいと思います
ストレスを抱えながらコミュニケーションを取っていますからその中で
せざ性が下がる
それが1点目ですそしてもう一つこれは
多様性を放置しているとイノベーションの芽をつぶしてしまうということなんです
21世紀はたような人たちの多様な愛デーが組み合わさって一人では決して実現でき
ないような事一つ一人では生み出さないようなものや世界を生み出していく
そういったことがモテの女られる時代ですですので多様性をイノベーションの原動力に
変えていただきたいと思っています
実際に多様性は想像力私たちの想像力の限界を超えるそのアイディアを私たちに与えて
くれる素晴らしい機会なんです
ですから
多様性を楽しんでいただきたいと思います
そこで今日は多様性に向き合う
我慢しないで向き合うという方法をみなさんにご紹介したいと思います
それがこちらです
多様性を力に変える4つの視点というものです
私たちの考えには必ず
必ずと言っていいほどね
背景に過去の経験と知識があります
そして価値観感情がそこにつながっています
考えを4点セットで4つの視点で捉えていく
これがポイントなんです
そうすると多様性に出会った時にもイラっとすることなく
そしてフラストレーションをためることなく好奇心をもって緩急することがとても簡単
になります
実体験を元にお話ししてみたいと思います
私が多様性の重要性を認識したのは20代の後半の頃なんです
この街日本橋で私はその当時実家の古い会社道
変革というのに描けていました
ビジネスクード卒業してすごく張り切っていたんですけれども
100面じゃくまの年米の企業
だいたい皆さんご想像できると思いますけれども変化することが非常に良い苦手でした
守るということはとても得意でしたけれども新しいことをどんどんやってみようって
いう空気ではなかったんです
ですから私はすごく困ってしまいました
そのときに私の姿をこの4点セットで分析してみたいと思います
私は変わることで会社が生き残るともちろん経営陣を一緒なんですが
考えていました実際に私たちのビジネスは金庫扉を作るというビジネスだったんですが
海外の企業ではやはり
業態変化を変容に成功した企業だけが生き残っていたんです
ですから均衡をずっと続け作り続けていても
atm の時代に治療産業になってしまうっていう大きな課題を抱えていました
企業の存続それから社員の雇用を守る
これが経営の先にということで非常に大きな危機感を持ってこの com ことに
取り組んでいたんです
しかし
周りの多くの人たちは何も変える必要がないと言いました
困ってしまいました古い会社だから仕方がないのかなと思ったんですがやっぱり
ちょっとキクミヨンということで私はいろんな方たちに話を聞き
回りました
その結果
とても興味ブライ深い結果が
的なんです
表面的に意見の違いというところではもう真っ向から対立しているわけですね香り必要
が必要ない
ところがこの経験価値観感情を掘り下げていくともう私は目いっぱい
彼が共感することができたんですそれはこういう話だったんです
私たちはセキュリティのビジネスをしていますセキュリティには
リスクというのはあってならないものなんですねっ
で地聞いてをやってる人達からしますと変わるということはリスクを生むことなんです
すごく精神的に望ましくない状態なんですね
神様が大事100%絶対
マモールっていうのが私たちのビジネスのプライドだったんです
ですから変化を柔軟にしていくっていうのは決して彼のビジネスモデルには合ってい
なかっ
ということがわかったんです
そのことが分かって私はそれまですごくフラストレーションを持っていて
マークばに来てもいたんですけれどもその彼らに対して尊敬の念を持てるようになり
ました
彼らは決して会社を変えたくないと言ってたわけではなかったんですね
pt のビジネスの精神を守りたいと言っていたわけだということが分かりました
そしてここから私とコミュニケーションも一変しました
それまでは毎日のようにねっ変わりましょうよ
やりましょうよその方が者せてありますよっていうふうに変わること
を一生懸命伝えていたんですがそれがむしろ彼らの不安を呼びかけていたということに
私も気づきましたのでそこからは彼らの不安になるだけ
あの
を刺激しないように話をするようにしましてそれでも時代の変化に合わせて
なぜ私たちが変わらなければならないのかということを
閉経や価値観のレベルでまたエネに話すことができました
そんな風に話をすることによって
私たちのプロジェクトは大成功に終わりました
ですので私たちの感謝まだ軍日
存続しております
その当時私は非常に試行錯誤でこのことをやっていました
ですのでこの4点セットがあの時の私にあったら持っていたらもっと楽だったのにと
思っています
もう一つこれは国家のレベルの話をしてみたいと思います
多様性を無視するとビジョンの教育ができないという間リーダーにとっては非常に重要
なあるいは国民にとっても授業かなと思うテーマだと思っていますそれをゆとり教育を
事例にお話ししてみたいと思います
い鳥教育
うちの子供が小学校の頃に始まったんです
皆さんもいい
いろんな経験があると思いますけれども
その頃
私の針の親たちはすごくパニックになっていました
ゆとり教育なんてありえない
宿に頼るしかないでしょ
そんな声が聞かれました
ちょうど私たちは受験戦争の前席にまあ育った親なんですね
そして将来の退学受験そして就職までは親の責任というふうに思っていましたから
このゆとり教育にとても怒ってしまったんです
その結果多くの親は低学年から塾に子どもたちを送り込むようになりました
1人教育だったはずなんですけど子どもたちのゆとりは実は奪われてしまったんです
その後10年後息子が大学に入りまして私は教育の世界に入ったんです
そこで初めて
この時ゆとり教育がなぜ始まっていたのかということを知ることになります
それがこちらです
当時の政策立案者は
日本の学力教育に行き詰っていました
そして時代の変化が非常にスピードを上げて言っていたという背景があります
そんな中で
自分の自ら学ぶ力ですとか
社会の変化に適応していく能力
そういったものを学力以外にもしっかりと学校で身につけなきゃいけないということを
まあ彼らは考え信じていとり教育を教育者の被害を持って初めていてくれたということ
お正実は後になって知ったんです
でも残念ながら政策立案者の願いは親たちには届きませんでした
ですのでリーダーはやはりしっかりと認識しなくてはいけないことがありますそれは
多様性を無視してはいけないした要請を
に向き合わないといけないそうしないともビジョンが共有できない
それは今でも実は同じ課題を抱えていると思います
教育の話もそうです最近話題になっている働き方改革もそうだと思います本当に私たち
はビジョンを共有して前に向かっているのか
それはリーダーの問題でもあるし私たち一人ひとりがその理解をできないことに対して
向き合っていくっていうことにつながっているのかなと思っています教育に関しては4
年前から9区のビジョンを親とか
まあ学校関係者企業の皆さんいろんなステークホルダーと共有するための
プラットフォームのようなものも立ち上げてそういった活動も微力ながらやっています
さて
良い未来を作る
食べに変化を起こすというとき
絶対にそこには対立意見の対立があるということをぜひ
認識していただきたいと思いますそしてそれは決して悪いことではなくてその対立の中
でいろんなアイディアを我々は見出すことができるし
もしかすると課題の方室に出会える可能性があります
そのためにはまず自分の考えを4点セットで4つの視点で見てください
自分の考えの背景には必ず経験がありますその経験を理解して自分の考えをメタ認知し
てください
その上で多様な意見な用の人たちの4つの視点も理解するようにしてくれ
しています
そうすると信頼関係が生まれてビジョンの共有にも迎えやすくなります
この話をしながら
やはりすごく大事だなと思うことは
多くの事柄はマルチしていくフォルダーでやらなければなりませんし
そしてチームで取り組まなければならないということです
そういう時その共同や競争にはこのステップが必ず必要だと思うんです
対立を対立のまま我慢するのでもなく放置するのではなくそこに向き合うことによって
自分の気づかなかった価値観
あれはもしかすると自分の思い込みや誤解
そういったものにも三木会える可能性が出てきます
最後にここで皆さんに是非
お願いしたいことがあります
4つの視点でそれぞれの考えを理解し
伝え引き合うたいわ
その対話を始めてください
多様性を的にするのではなく
放置するのでもなく
を味方につけてチームで課題に向き合うとき
良い未来に向かって
大きな変化を
作り出すことが可能です
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]